the people who say they defend our
democracy are the people most likely to
undermine our democracy the people who
pretend to be the radicals overthrowing
the system or the people who are most
likely to defend and entrench the system
in place it's ironic you can see it play
out right now in a debate happening
between nicki minaj and joy reid
you know
a meeting of the great philosophers of
our era
nicki minaj is right here
joy reid is not right here but you're
gonna see joy read is very rarely right
but you're gonna see not just that one
side is right and one side is wrong it's
it's not a battle really between the
conservatives and the left or the left
and the right or anything like that it's
between
the outsiders and the ruling class
the the
entrenched power versus the people nicki
minaj tweets out they want you to get
vaccinated for the met gala if i get
vaccinated it won't be for the mech
gallop it'll be once i feel i've done
enough research i'm working on that now
in the meantime my loves be safe wear a
mask with two strings that grip your
hand and face grip your head and face
not that loose one so she's saying wear
the mask i'm going along with a lot of
this but i'm a little skeptical of this
hastily developed drug that we've been
hearing some weird stuff about
then she goes on to give a little
anecdote she goes
this is graphic so you know maybe close
your ears for 10 seconds if you need to
my cousin and trinidad won't get the
vaccine because his friend got it and
became impotent his testicles became
swollen his friend was weeks away from
getting married now the girl called off
the wedding so just pray on it and make
sure you're comfortable with your
decision not bullied well man if
anything is going to convince you not to
get the vaccine it will be that so she's
giving this anecdote but even beyond
this one anecdote
we've all heard these stories and the
cdc and the fda have actually
acknowledged a number of these stories
of perfectly young healthy people
getting myocarditis there's a 13 year
old who died a few days after he
received the second vaccine of heart
inflammation he was otherwise totally
healthy there have been people who died
of blood clots after getting the vaccine
that were related to the vaccine there
are people who have gotten nerve
disorders from the vaccines these things
actually have
happened
joy reid on msnbc
furiously responds people like nicki
minaj i have to say this
you have a platform sister that is 22
million followers okay i have two
million followers you have 22 million
followers on twitter for you to use your
platform to encourage our community to
not protect themselves and save their
lives my god sister you could do better
than that you got that platform
it's a blessing it's a blessing that you
got that that people listen to you and
they listen to you more they listen to
me
for you to use your platform to put
people in the position of dying from a
disease they don't have to die from oh
my god as a fan as a hip-hop fan and
somebody was your fan i'm so sad that
you did that so sad that you did that
sister so joy reid is engaging in what
is called concern trolling this this is
not the kind of trolling where you just
attack somebody outright this is the
kind of trolling where you pretend to be
on the person's side but you're actually
opposing everything that they're doing
in your training saying oh look i'm a
big fan of yours oh i just think i love
you oh i love your music and you're so
great and so i'm just i'm really sad
that you're that you're contradicting
the establishment narrative i'm just it
really concerns me that you are stepping
out of line from the ruling classes
narrative nicki minaj i'm just because
i'm a big fan of yours i know the
dilemma you want to invest in physical
gold
but you're not old rich uncle penny bags
and so you feel that you cannot come out
of pocket and start buying physical gold
well what if i told you you can start
investing in physical gold for as little
as 30 a month you lie michael i don't i
don't lie i don't like calm down okay
you can do that with acre acre allows
you to invest in their gold bars
subscribe to their gold bars and then
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your door they've also
got a new 100 a month subscription to a
5 gram gold bar if you want to up the
ante i have really enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals
i think it's a good investment to make
especially in kind of crazy
economic times such as the ones we're
living in i've enjoyed investing in acre
gold right now go to
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
this url because acres giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweeter post why you should be the
recipient mention at get underscore acre
that's getacregle.com knowles thank you
aker gold for supporting the show
so what does nicki minaj does she say oh
well okay i'm sorry joy you're right i
shouldn't have stepped out of line
maybe next time maybe you should get the
vaccine no she doesn't do any of that
she says quote
this is what happens when you're so
thirsty to down another black woman by
the request of the white man that you
didn't bother to read all my tweets my
god sister do better imagine getting
your dumb derriere on tv a minute after
a tweet to spread a false narrative a
black about a black woman the two white
men sitting there not in their heads
because this uncle tom tamiana doing the
work child how sad
i love it i love it i know that she's
going after white people here and that's
i don't think that's good i think that's
bad for white people and i think it's
bad for swarthy people and i think it's
bad for the country in general but
to take it from nicki minaj's
perspective here
if you
the
the way that she is using the white man
here
is i think synonymous with the ruling
class okay i think the the wish the ma
you know you ever hear about the man all
the man the man's getting me down or the
white man is you know
i think she's using this expression not
not to express her
hatred for white people in general maybe
she hates white people too i don't know
but i think she's using it to say
not you are a black shill for white
people
but you are a shill for the ruling power
the ruling class now the fact the fact
is the the ruling class is not presently
defined by race or sex it's not the
white man it's the blob right it's it's
what we're talking about we call it the
liberal establishment call it whatever
you want
and
if you read nicki minaj's tweet as i
think you should in that way she's
completely right
she says this is what happens when
you're so thirsty to attack another
black woman she's saying look we're
supposed to be on the same side here
we're out of the power structure except
joy reads not out of the power structure
she's within the she works for corporate
media and her job is to push the
propaganda of the liberal establishment
you're doing this at the request of the
establishment
you're spreading a false narrative about
you coming after me who you have
something in common with but you're
doing it because you've sold out to the
establishment
this
i think is absolutely right this is what
aoc did too
when aoc shows up to the met gala to the
fancy party with all her extremely rich
friends where no one's wearing a mask
and no one's following their own rules
other than the staff other than the
filthy dirty help so they don't spread
their germs to the good rich people and
she wears a dress and says text the rich
she is
she is doing
what i accuse the squishy conservatives
of doing you know i call those squishy
conservatives the court jesters and the
kingdom of liberalism well aoc is the
same thing she's the same thing for the
left she is performing this role as a
radical leftist revolutionary she is
doing nothing but propping up the
capitalistic liberal establishment
plutocracy that's that's her job she's a
she is a court jester
for the radical left and she puts on a
show and she's supposed to get all the
leftists really riled up but her her job
really is to preserve the establishment
that's why she's partying with people at
the med gala
when we talk about people on the right
who are the sort of conservatives who go
on the liberal channels and they say
well i'm a conservative but i would
never support donald trump i'm a
conservative but i would never support
pro-life laws i'm a conservative but i
would never support borders and
immigration controls i'm a conservative
but i would never support you know
anything that's actually conservative
they are court jesters on the right and
aoc and joy reid are court jesters on
the left
their job is to put up just enough of a
fight to give the radical leftists the
feeling that they can really
completely overthrow the
broad liberal establishment
which is not opposed to the big
corporations but is actually part of the
big corporations in fact though when
those when those corporate
establishmentarian masters come down and
say hey
hey joy reid
hey aoc
hey
people that we permit to have some power
in this system
get in line
and get the rest of your people in line
too
what do they do
they do it hey joy reid hey aoc
jump
how high how high corporate overlords
and nicki minaj isn't going to do that
hey hold up before you go before you go
maybe leave me a comment on youtube
maybe subscribe here but most
importantly this is what i need from you
okay i'm just talking you mono amano
okay eye to eye face to face man to man
or woman or whatever
head on over to apple podcast stitcher
spotify google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show hit that subscribe button
it's very simple just
just kiss it then it it'll download and
then we can avoid some of the
censorship that goes on in certain
quarters we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]